november is alzheimer's disease
awareness month and family caregivers
month
the keep memory live organization is
also giving us a month of memories and a
fabulous way for us to give back
rocky theis is live at del montego state
house inside the venetian to tell us how
we can
dine at a distance hi rocky
hi kirsten yes so month of memories is
keep memory alive's newest way
to give back and fundraise for you know
research money right it's for uh
caregiver support so
november is alzheimer's awareness month
for people with suffering from
alzheimer's disease and so we have uh
wonderful initiatives going on this
month that help support our caregiver
support programs and education
absolutely at the ruvo center here
locally we want to give back to the
patients and also their families because
they're going through the disease
as well as the patients so let's talk
about why we're here at del monaco
steakhouse first and foremost for the
first initiative
dying at a distance yes dining at a
distance you can go online to
keepmemorylife.org
and we have multiple restaurants that
are participating at dining at a
distance
you can purchase a voucher for either a
prefix
menu item or carryout so you can
actually carry out
for multiple friends at your home and
have your own private social distancing
definitely perfect for the times of
course and obviously you can get all of
this amazing food coming up later in the
show we're going to talk to the chef
behind all of this so let's also talk
about the organization keep memory alive
of course
this is what you guys do you give back
to alzheimer's research and
families but how are families dealing
with the current situation
well you know there's been a lot of
isolation and especially people that
have alzheimer's and dementia really
feel it
being isolated but we've had wonderful
virtual platforms that we created
so the caregiver can go on with their
family member
and actually participate in fine fine
arts
you know class that they have awesome
caregiver support groups and also
educational series luncheon learns every
wednesday beautiful but all this uh keep
memory alive
you know does events to support
everything that we do for caregivers at
the laureva center
perfect and lastly here the other
initiatives besides dine at a distance
what are those
so we have a wonderful different
restaurants
and retailers and bars that participate
in a specialty cocktail
they create a specialty cocktail for the
month of november
and all the proceeds uh come back to
support whatever amount that that
restaurant wants to give
okay to the revo center perfect well
coming up later we're going to talk to
the chef behind all this again so i'm
excited
to start tasting this food it's been in
front of me for a while now yes we want
to thank the entire community and all
the restaurants that are participating
and all the initiatives that are
happening well thank you so much jody
for your work too i'll send it back to
you guys thank you